with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller Von Miller
[Music]
howdy guys welcome to this week's Vaughn
cast
um it's an honor the privilege to be
with you guys each and every week
um we had a really really good game on
this LastPass week here in Buffalo
um versus the Miami Dolphins and the
Buffalo Bills it was a crazy game it was
a tough game you know they had uh beat
us earlier in the season we knew coming
to this game we wanted to give you know
everything that we had we're gonna have
to you know come out there and take it
one play at a time and all the cliche
stuff just to have a chance to uh win
this game they have a really really good
team really really good defense and it
only got better when they traded for
Bradley Chubbs so we knew coming to this
game we had to you know cross our T's
and Dot our eyes just to have a chance
in this game
um I watched the game at home because
it's supposed to snow like crazy and um
you know even though like I can walk and
I'm walking good and stuff I just didn't
you know want to put myself in that type
of snowy like
like sloshy like treasuring around in
the snow like environment you know two
weeks after surgery so I stayed at home
which was uh which was cool you know the
only thing about you know staying at
home that's different from going to the
game is you know I can't be there with
my teammates I don't get to see you know
my guys on the other team you know I'm
just at home you know chilling but
that's just the place where I got to be
right now because I'm only two weeks
after surgery when watching the game
like I'm not gonna lie like and I was on
my toes the whole game like Tula was
playing out of his mind
um you know their defense was was
playing great as well
um and it was really really a tough game
and we really really needed that win and
Miami Dolphins really really needed that
win so I'm not gonna lie you know I was
nervous you know when I'm playing in the
game I never get nervous but I'm at home
watching my boys and I was nervous
um
but
this game Josh Allen the Buffalo Bills
that came out on top and it just showed
me a lot about my team and showed me
that these guys know how to win these
guys can play in tough conditions and
fight it out these guys can blow teams
out these guys can play close games and
win them too so it showed me a lot about
my team it also showed me
what type of guys we got in the locker
room because you see the offensive
lineman clearing out the the ground
clearing out the snow for Tyler bass to
kick a kick it was a it was a kick to
put us over the top we really needed
that kick and we had our alignment out
there you know uh sweeping the the turf
you know I think it was like I think it
was like five linemen out there just
sweeping the turf it looked like it
looked like he was trying to clean your
room up like your mama said hey uh this
room still ain't clean y'all about to
get a whooping and they just went crazy
you and your homeboys they just come in
there and they just started cleaning up
real fast but it just shows you the type
of guys that we got to look in the
locker room man it was super cool to see
those guys out there doing that and um
you know it was a it was a coach snowy
game
but my guest that I have on the show
tonight is use to code snowy games
um this is my dog
this is my this is my this is one of my
my close friends on and off the football
field I got real love not just football
love but real brotherly love for this
guy he was a pro bowl
um selection
um out of NC State
the Broncos number five overall pick in
2018
he's been a Denver's maker he's been a
Difference Maker in Denver until this
year's trade deadline when he moved to
South Beach to join the Miami Dolphins
this is my guy Bradley Chubb Chad what's
up mobile
what's going on my boy you good
I'm good man hey this was the snow
different like was it different than how
we played in Denver in the code games in
Denver
I feel like cold is cold bro like it's
probably like a little like that wet
cold compared to the dry cold like I'm
saying being on the lake and all that I
feel like it was like a little [ __ ]
like sharper you know what I mean but
yeah for the most part man you got to
heat the benches on the sideline you got
the heaters going so you only really
feel it when you're on the field and at
that point you're moving and stuff so it
wasn't terrible when that snow came you
start to feel it a little bit too so I
think it's the wind that that makes
sense too but it's the wind once you
start playing though like once you start
playing and you got the jacket on the
sidelines there's a heater and you're
running around bro it's not really that
it's not really that tough and you know
everybody out there we want to win so I
think I don't think guys really out
there thinking about the code no way
yeah your mind doesn't even go there
like you said you want to win you want
to compete you want to do all that so
you can't the guys don't even let their
mind get there so that's how I took it
man and just tried to go out there and
do my thing you you did do your thing
man so how was it with Bill's Mafia
throwing snowballs I've never seen that
you know I've been here that was my
first time seeing that too and I'm
watching it on TV I'm like bro like
they gonna say something about this soon
because it's basically an extra element
on defense the guy's running around and
then boom hitting the face right what
was y'all saying what y'all saying on
the on the on the sideline when y'all
seen that honestly bro at first it was
it was just like threw us off a little
bit because I saw the first one go by
and then I saw like more of them come
and I was like okay that probably lasts
for a little bit The Ref said something
about it and then as soon as the ref
said something about it they start
throwing more and more I'm like okay
yeah that's gonna be something that we
don't have to deal with our game and
then one of them actually like skipped
to hit one of my teammates and his back
didn't really hit his head but hit like
his shoulder pad and he like looked back
wanting to get into the fans and I
remember uh bake just turned around so
he's like hey man that's what they want
bro that's what they want they want you
to turn around get out your game so I
mean uh it was a element that you don't
really can't really prepare for you know
I'm saying something that that Bill's
Mafia created and stood on it you know
I'm saying that whole game so we just
gotta be ready be better ready for it
next time we come up there you know it
just shouldn't snow you know if they
just yeah
and they just don't have snow out there
they can't throw the stuff but you know
I'm with you on that too fam like
football is already it's already tough
now we dealing with snowballs too yeah
you know I'm with y'all on that man but
it's Bill's Mafia man it's crazy here
man they crazy man football man they
they they do everything to try to you
know put us in situations for the wind
but you know I'm sure the NFL will crack
down on that man we don't need that to
win you know what I'm saying but it was
it was it was different to see that man
and you know a lot has been made about
the cold
and the code and tour tour had a strong
game you know he really bounced back
from the game uh that he played with the
Los Angeles Chargers
um you know what did that tell you about
your new quarterback what did they tell
you about your new quarterback
everything he can't play in the snow he
went out there and went crazy he had he
had a you know he had a tough game the
week before but he bounced back and Run
game was on point he was running around
dotting or did they tell you about your
your quarterback man he got it in him
man he got that dog in him man and just
to like like everything being throughout
the league and throughout College you
hear about him in college you hear about
the type of Duty he is and all that and
okay yeah I want to meet the dude and uh
he lived up to every expectation man
he's positive in the locker room he does
everything right he's the right guy to
the people working around the facility
as well so
um when he had success on the fields no
surprise because he does all the right
things each and every day throughout the
week so and then like just to uh to like
his performances against the with the
Chargers and the 49ers whatever people
want to downplay but at the end of the
day man he he was in position to do
stuff he did a lot of great things in
those games and then the Bills game was
just a showing of of
um of him and his receivers being on the
same page and you've seen how really
lethal it could get that old line
holding up against y'all's a great front
man and just uh just just showing how
how he could command the team how you
can lead a team and he's one of my
favorite teammates man just how he
approaches every day how he talks to
people how he just smiling no matter
what the situation is he's smiling it
calls everybody ooze because you know
he's Simone or whatever so what up baby
ooh so the same dude day too man so uh I
got a lot of love and respect for one
for sure
man that's dope man I've been a huge fan
of tour since he came in in Alabama and
won the game for him I think with Jayla
it was Jalen Hersey came in for Jalen
hurts exactly and he won the game for
Alabama came back with some crazy passes
man I've been a fan of of tour for a
very long time
um you know but it was crazy like
everybody's talking about snow is gonna
be this it's gonna be that
um and there was a lot being made about
the Dolphins playing in cold weather and
you know me and my mom said I'm like bro
like the office they play the Jets they
play the Buffalo Bills and and they
played the New England Patriots and
every single team in the National
Football League is gonna have to play in
in some kind of cold game it don't
matter where your home stadium is you
know how did you guys uh prepare for
that you know in the locker room and
stuff yeah man it was a lot of talk
about it you know what I mean but at the
end of the day we just kind of like took
our minds there like I said when you're
out there running around and doing all
the things you got to do to win the game
you're not really thinking about the
code and stuff like that but throughout
the week man we turned the AC up in the
indoor trying to get as cold as possible
just like trying to do everything to
like get our mind off the code like talk
about it as much as we can but hey when
we come down to this game time we're not
talking about it at all we're just out
there doing what we do you know what I
mean and different guys prepare for that
differently I'm saying some people put
on two three layers some people go out
there no shirt so I feel like once we
got there everybody was in the right
mindset for sure so and like you said
man all three of our uh other opponents
in the division in the code so if we
want to really do what we say we want to
do and and uh meaningful football deep
December football we're gonna have to go
up there in those cold games and and and
do go out there and play to the best of
our ability man just can't let it get
the rest of us yeah man it's it's not
that crazy man I put like you I forgot
what it's what it's called I think it's
like warm skin I'll put the warm skin on
all over my body you know for regular
code games I just put it the the little
the cold gear long sleeve on but for
cold cold games and I just put the warm
skin on it and then I put the sleeve on
put the warm skin on my legs and I put
the sleeves on you know the thing is
if you if you make sure your feet good
like if you put the little foot warmer
feet you put the little foot the little
uh the little soul warmer and then you
just stay in your jacket and you stay by
the heater bro like you really don't
even you really don't even know man but
the only place it has the fingers in the
hands bro you gotta you gotta make sure
that was good because we're using them
every plate you know what I mean we use
them in your when your fingers go it's
over with at that point so you gotta
make sure to fit those fingers stay good
but everything after that I mean you
straight that code ain't that bad I'll
wait right until like you know they
telling it the play about to start in
like 10 seconds I have my I have my
fingers damn near in the heater like
yeah and then you hear you you smell
like you smell like rubber burning [ __ ]
right half my fingers damn near in that
heater man and then right before like
you say you know defense they say
offense ready to go in 10 seconds rep
and say 10 seconds and then I run out
there man it ain't really that bad get a
little warm up on the way out for sure
yeah man but y'all yeah yeah coach is
super cool man speaking of cold weather
and he had a shirt on that said I wish
it were colder and he had wore it in
practice how is how is coach McDowell
man he seems like he seems like a a
pretty cool like young coach I played
for Coach McVeigh last year so I know
how like refreshing that can be to have
somebody you know as exciting and you
know ready to go and you know he's
younger and he just connects with the
guys a little bit a little bit
differently how's coach McDaniel hey
like you said man he's his Vibe man
everybody just could attract to it you
know what I mean and it's never like
he's trying too hard doing too much or
nothing like that man he's just being
himself every day you know what I mean
it's funny we got those shirts because
when I first got here they uh for
camping stuff they had shirts that said
I wish it were hotter so like just
trying to like get your mindset in the
right space so but like I said man it
was one of the uh one really good dude
one really good coach man and uh his
team means are hilarious he throws like
those little jokes out there that people
don't really get at first and then you
start sitting on you like okay that's
what he was saying and uh challenges
everybody you know what I mean and
um it's not like that challenge where
it's like oh man what is this dude
talking about like he really wants the
best from you the best out of you uh
there's no like gray area how he feels
about you and stuff like that and what
you got to do like that everybody
respects everybody loves man it's hard
not to go out there on Sunday and put
out everything for it you know what I
mean and one thing I admire about him
and he finds a positive in any situation
too like this three-game losing streak
we don't man he's been probably the most
happy most positive dude that around the
facility you know what I mean and
um coaches you know me know how they get
they could get oh man my job online so
boom I gotta do this I gotta do that I
gotta start reaching but he being cool
cool collected the whole time man I
respect it a lot
you know GM GM Vaughn I like to put my
GM hat on you know Toms and it looked
good on YouTube Hey I I appreciate you
man Gino Miller you know I think I think
I can do it man
um you know and I like to put my hat on
and I like to look at like you know
athletic training staff and
strengthening conditioning staff like
what type of front office guys do I run
around me and you know what type of
coaches that you want to bring into and
there are multiple ways to skin a cat
like we had you know coach fanzio her
defense was crazy still crazy you know
it's still crazy because a coach fansio
the Denver Broncos defense is still
crazy because of coach fangio and the
things that he instilled in that defense
from you know 10 hands 10 feet you know
everybody being in like you could never
take that away from coach fanzio even
though we didn't win like the way we
wanted to like when it come to that
defense when it comes to playing when it
comes to playing against anybody I don't
care who it is like it could be Lamar
Jackson it could be it could be uh
Derrick Henry he gonna have some form
man so it's it's multiple ways there's
multiple coaches that you could get make
coach McDaniel you um I like coach
McDaniel style like coach mcveigh's
style I like coach McDermott who he's
kind of like a mix of like hard nose
like tough he used to be a wrestler like
tough defensive mind and Coach but he's
evolved into like more of a quarterback
coach and more of like a you know I
wouldn't even say softer but more of a
he's evolved to better deal with Josh
Allen in the offense that we have and
Josh Allen's personality and you know
it's cool to hear you know things about
coaches because you know I started
thinking like man what type of Coach you
know I'm gonna bring in you know the
same organization or or to keep my
organization going man so it's dope to
you know hear it about Coach McDaniel um
when you got traded
um did Coach McDaniel call you like
right after you got traded I'm sure they
already knew but like how did that
conversation go whenever you talked to
Coach McDaniel yeah so you know I got a
call from the Broncos first talked to
them about the whole situation and then
uh Chris Greer the GM out here he
actually called me next and he was in
the room with coaching McDaniels too so
I talked to Chris for a little bit man
just got a chance to talk to him
um thank him for the opportunity you
know and just be as transparent as
possible man just like one of those
things really changed my life it helped
me get back into that mindset of of who
I really am and
um I knew why they would bring me here
to help win football games and as soon
as I got off the phone with Mr Greer
coach McDaniel came on pretty much
relayed the same message Man and just
welcomed me with open arms whatever I
needed he said he got me he gave his uh
his wife my girlfriend's number in order
to you know I'm saying for them to reach
out and coordination stuff as well so
like I said man it's been all love since
I since I got the call that I was going
to be a dolphin man and uh coach
McDaniel and Mr Gray they've been a a
part of that and as soon as I got here
man all the teammates show love too so
it's been love man it's been uh it's
been amazing being out here in South
Beach man you can't complain in that
sunny weather every day
you can't complain at all brother so
it's been good I can't lie did you did
you cry when in Denver I did crazy you
did I didn't I didn't cry on the trade I
ain't Crown the trail I cried you ain't
cry like I was crying
no I cry I ain't crying like you was
crying bro you were sick dog I mean for
sure why not why not be sick Bro yeah I
mean I'm sick I was sick for you too bro
but now I didn't cry that day but I for
sure cried the day before I signed the
contract bro I I let off some tears in
that hotel room man my mom was there she
came down just like helped me settle in
and stuff and I remember balling man
just like man just because that's all
that's what you play for man that's what
you it was it uh put the work in for was
it like those tears that you had when
you went to your first pro bowl like you
could barely talk like
was it that type was it we got to get
some footage of Bradley crying hey man
don't get me like that man don't do me
like that nah yeah it was not like them
tears though ain't gonna tell you I
ain't gonna lie to you I had the dry
heaves
so it felt good though for sure to let
it all out oh man like like you had said
bro like bro that's what it's about bro
for you to achieve your Gene your dream
and start talking about them numbers and
you start talking about you know you
start thinking about the things that you
could do for your family you start
thinking about your life like after this
bro like and then you just have a little
flashback right you have a little
flashback when you was a little kid and
you hoping and praying and and you you
praying to God that I could go there and
make it and when you finally like get
that deal and you in Miami of all places
and you had you would have teamed that
that love you that want you that need
you you know it's a different thing man
when I when I walked into so what did it
for me is
you know when I was with the Denver
Broncos it was like it was just like Von
like you know because I had been there
through everybody's I saw everybody grow
up like and it was just I was just fun
you know it was you know you you you so
far removed from you know Super Bowl 50
and you know all the pro bowls that you
went to and all the crazy plays that I
had did when I was younger and people
just and all the wins were Peyton
Manning and you know everybody in the
locker room they just just be like boom
boom you know oh it's just fun man it's
just fun then when I went to the to the
Realms it was like man we got Von Miller
like yeah you know bro talk to us about
it talk to us about Super Bowl we're
like what what it's gonna take bro like
yeah Aaron Donald right here got Leonard
Floyd coach McVeigh like you know he
coach McVeigh is he was 35 years old and
I was I was 32 at the time like he only
like you know a couple of years you know
yeah older than me so it was like damn
like everybody vibing like everybody
they want me here like they asking me
you know what type of games that we want
to run you remember in the room with
pegs and and uh and uh and coaching them
you try to put a game in they were like
man you know we're gonna run it this way
yeah yeah that's what we're doing and
you go to another team and they're
asking you what you like man let's let's
get you an A.D let's start figuring out
stuff so for me it was like refreshing
bro like and then they go from like you
know you know from like a team that was
you know rebuilding and struggling and
trying to find their way to a team that
just needs you right now man
um how was that like when you walked in
I know we talked about it for a little
bit but how was it like when you walked
into the facility for the first time my
bad but financially again like I was in
LA and I honestly it was like a dream
for me like yeah like when I wake up in
the morning I'll be like damn like is
this [ __ ] real I'm like damn like am I
really like am I really in La did I
really get traded and then the blinds
come open and I'm like bro I'm really in
L.A I play for the Los Angeles Rams bro
did you have any of those type moments
when you got with your new team yeah for
sure bro so you know how they Center
they they fly you uh to the new team
pretty much the same day or the next day
so I went the same night and um you know
I mean go to the hotel and I don't get
there till like 2 A.M so boom 2 A.M and
then 6 a.m is a physical so I barely get
any sleep in any of that so just drive
up kind of in like zombie mode as I'm
doing all that and then it's like about
nine o'clock at this time we head to the
facility and I just remember like waking
up man like it just got a boat joke
energy out of nowhere saw the the whole
facility the stadium kind of like right
next to it too so you kind of see
everything all at once the gates opened
up man it was just uh it was me and Jeff
Wilson in the car and I just remember
like just looking around smiling like
just cheesing just knowing because all
the opportunities I was there you know
what I mean so
um I remember the man just walking in
seeing it the honestly brother this new
facility that the Dolphins got dog
looked like a resort man it's crazy like
everything's updated to the T it's crazy
man it's it's a night nothing bad about
Denver's facility is all but you know
it's been there for for as long as
you've been there but this one just got
built this year or last year or whatever
so it's like a whole new thing you know
what I mean so it's crazy honestly but
um yeah man when I walked in I was like
yo am I really here and like I said my
mom came down that first day we taking
pictures in front of the dolphin stuff
I'm like yo this is this is crazy they
bring my jersey out they do all this
stuff I'm like man like it's it's really
happening I go to practice go to walk
through
um everything's just moving so fast and
I remember just getting back to my hotel
room like bro yeah I'm I'm really out
here like it's really time to do this
now you know what I mean and uh it was
crazy for sure yeah so now that you
don't have some time to reflect you know
how do you feel about you know leaving
Denver like how does that you know what
what type of emotions now because I'm
sure like right when it happened like
that was that was right when you happen
but you know weeks going now like you
know you have some time to like reflect
and kind of gather your thoughts and
your emotions you know how does it feel
now
uh it still felt like bro like I I just
had so much unfinished Endeavor you know
what I mean and uh that's what was the
most like sad part at the beginning when
I first got traded it just felt like I I
didn't really get over the hump that I
wanted to you know what I mean we were
not the best teamwork we weren't winning
as much as we wanted to and I feel like
uh when I first got there okay yeah I'm
still a rookie still learning my way
whatever boom boom injuries caught up
and stuff like that and then at that
point I'm like okay this is my time this
is where we're gonna win this we're
gonna do this and then boom uh
disappointment again so uh it just felt
like all my all my things that I had
left open in Denver like even me and you
bro I feel like we didn't have as many
great Seasons as we know we could have
you know what I mean that first one we
popped off went crazy and then boom I go
down and you go down and then uh you
know I'm saying you know how that goes
and uh so just unfinished business is
what I felt man and I just don't want to
have that same feeling out here in Miami
you know what I mean I'm getting with
these guys I'm trying to be the best
teammate learning a lot of stuff from
you bro honestly a lot of stuff you
taught me and a lot of stuff you not
even know you taught me the last stuff
you just did
um as a person I'll start pick up on
that trying to do that with my new
teammates and stuff like that and
um the the biggest thing like I said
just like that unfinished business man
but like I said I'm not gonna have that
same feeling out here in Miami man I got
a lot of good guys around me I got a lot
of guys with dogs who want to win they
want to get after it
um so it's gonna be fun man I'm excited
to go on this new Journey
for me it felt like my wife after 11
years rolled over in the bed looked at
me and said I don't want to be with you
no more
find somebody else
as a matter of fact I don't know
somebody else yeah and as a matter of
fact you need to be going tomorrow and
I'm seeing you in La I know you I know
you're like La just she sent me to like
the place where I have just just just
get out of here get out of here go have
fun bye just just get out of here I know
we had some good times I know we've been
together for 11 years but yeah I don't
want to be with you no more that's how
that's how I felt to me man but you know
what now that the Hot Shot looking at
things like bro it was it was definitely
you know for the best man and this is
for the best for you man all the things
all the adversity that we've been
through like for and all the things that
we wanted to do with the Denver Broncos
all the things that we saw that team
doing like you get to pour all of that
energy into your new team yeah you know
what I'm saying it's just experience
it's just experience you you like you
are you're you're gonna be a captain
next year like you got so much
experience so much leadership and you
learned all that through the adversity
that we had with the Denver Broncos
and they go back to what you said
earlier too bro I feel like the tears
when they came I feel like I started
thinking about it to that too like just
the adversity man all the stuff that
would have killed a lot of people you
know what I mean put a lot of people in
their tracks and they had them that
stopped going and just the stuff that we
just overcome and um we just do it just
because we love it man and just to get
the life-changing money generational
money just to help our families out off
something that God gave us a disability
to do it's just dope man so that's
another thing so you you was number nine
years number nine in college
he was number 55 with the Denver Broncos
then you come to the Miami Dolphins and
you pick number two what what is the
what is the story behind that it looked
dope on you like I tell you right it
looks so sweet bro you got the towel you
got the spat yeah that all white with
the socks like long sleeves like bro it
looked good on your own boy like what's
your story behind it yeah man so uh I
remember as soon as I got the call from
that was getting traded after I'm saying
after I talked to Coachman damn Mr Green
all that I got on a roster bro so boom
see what numbers are open and then
um I was looking at all the numbers and
I saw Chase Edmonds was number two and I
saw okay yeah we just traded Chase Evans
for me so the number two is open and
then I was looking down it was like 57
was open uh
like a lot of numbers that I just did
because 55 Jerome Baker got that I know
he'd been here for a while big vet
um does a lot of great things on the
field so I know I wasn't going to just
see him saying hey bro can I get that I
know it wasn't gonna happen like that so
uh just went for the best one after that
bro I felt like two was that best one
and I texted my agent as soon as I saw
the roster I was like hey yo make sure I
get two make sure I get two and he was
like oh all right you got it and then uh
so at that point it was just the what
looked the best but then when I started
like reflecting and sitting down talking
my mom and all that
um I just started to like just it's like
a part two for me it's like my second
chapter of my adult life uh all my adult
life I've been in Denver you know what I
mean and just like the second part of
that growing up just taking new elevated
levels man just just taking everything
to a new level my play my my off the
field stuff my my relationships my you
know what I mean just everything in my
life man it's just a part two for that
so it's like a whole new whole new start
man a whole new city whole new
everything so I'm just excited bro just
to be a whole new person that feel like
you know what I mean
you know I'm putting my Jeep my GM hat
on again Denver Broncos they traded you
and a 20 25 fifth round pick for Chase
Edmonds and a 2023 first round pick and
a 2024 fourth round pick how does that
make you feel that the Miami Dolphins
sent all of that to get Bradley chubbed
that's got to make you feel like
how does that make you feel my boy
uh on top of the world bro honestly man
just to know like I said bro it makes
you think back to all the stuff that
you've been through all the stuff that
you uh fought through to get to that
point and like to just to see it it
wasn't going unnoticed you know what I
mean sometimes you like might do
something and like oh nobody saw that
man like I just put my all into that
nobody noticed it or whatever I'ma just
do it again you know what I mean and you
start seeing those little wins add up
add up and uh when you see it all come
out like the way it did man it's just
dope it's just like a a self-fulfilling
feeling it's one of those things that
you want it again you don't want to want
that feeling to stop you want to
continue to try to be the best man and
with all the talent in this league now
man it's gonna be hard it's gonna have
to push you to have to make you you know
I'm saying 10 times better uh in off
season then during the season and stuff
like that too so I mean it was like it
was a blessing man just to be wanted be
felt be all that and and trying to bring
all that energy out here to Miami now
for sure man I ain't gonna lie man still
got my GM my GM hat on when you look at
it y'all got
Jay Howard yo y'all got number eight
that's number eight the strong safety
that's Holland right yeah Snowman from
uh from uh Oregon right yeah Oregon yep
cold cold like when he when he healthy
like bro he he's young but he wanted the
best he wanted the best in the lead
y'all got Jalen Phillips on the other
side you know that's you know you know I
be knowing about the young passwords too
you got you going over there he got he
got some stuff to him too I'm excited to
see this development bro he nice he got
a motor over there
um yeah I got two great inside
linebackers y'all can get Byron Jones
back too
um yeah I got two of them y'all got
Tyrique Hill y'all got Jalen waddle
Mozart y'all got Tyrone Armstead bro
y'all got bro y'all boys got a squad
family yeah I'm sure you I'm sure you
super excited to be over there man it's
gonna be a lot of great things coming
from the Miami Dolphins but it was a lot
of crazy things that happened this week
as well you know we had the craziest
the the craziest the largest the wildest
comeback in NFL history the Vikings
versus the Colts I think the Vikings
were up were down 33 points yeah that's
crazy and and the Colts just gave it
away but I don't think they gave it away
so I don't think they gave it away not
necessarily because you know I'm sitting
there watching the game in real time and
all the coach all the all the things
that that coach Saturday was doing like
those are the things that you do to put
your team in situations to win they
didn't happen for him but you know
sometimes they try to blame the head
coach this ain't no but he was he did
everything for his team to win I just
think from a momentum standpoint that
the Vikings just had it like so no
matter what they was doing not from a
place standpoint anything like that is
just from a momentum standpoint like
right when the Vikings start right when
they got 21 points in they started
feeling like okay we can win this game
and once you get to that that situation
once you got mind control over the other
team
like it's just a matter of time where
and they had too much time on the clock
and Kurt's cousins brought him back did
you get a chance to check that game out
yeah I got a chance to check it out bro
so uh we're playing later that day and
it's crazy too bro because the the Colts
went up 23-0 at one point and I remember
looking at my brother I was like man if
I can come back bro I'm not even trying
to be funny I'm not even trying to lie
right now I mean I said the Vikings
gonna come back bro
um don't even worry about him and my
agent because they were they were both
you know what I'm saying talking about
the game and stuff I said they're gonna
come back but I feel like they're gonna
come back and then boom let's just
slowly start doing it slowly start doing
it and then like you said bro once you
get that momentum and what's the Vikings
record like 10 and 3 11 and 2 or
something yeah that's three games yep
yeah ten and three so like when you're a
team that knows how to win that that's
used to putting those those tough games
um you just find ways to win those games
like that so I didn't really see
um the Colts holding on to that win man
I'm glad I'm not glad it's uh yeah
this one came back on us too they came
here one last minute too so I was like
man hey the Vikings really know they
know they know how to win they know how
to win man it ain't never out they got
and once that crowd start clapping it's
over with man oh man it's crazy man
we've been there you know we went there
last year man we got a chance to
experience you know the Vikings the show
they got a great fan base man and you
just I mean I just saw like the momentum
it was it didn't even have to it didn't
even have anything to do with the play
calls or anything like that I just it
just felt like the Vikings had just
sucked all the momentum out of of the
coats man and that was that was one of
the craziest games it definitely was one
of the crazy games because it was you
know the largest comeback in NFL history
but it was another crazy game
the Raiders versus the Patriots and our
guy Chandler Jones yes with the game
winning that was a formal recovery or
that was that in it that's I don't know
what you call that man you call it a
touchdown Game Center I don't know what
you call it though
Mac Jones stay up going to the end zone
arms out with the hero Pros like bro I
yelled I ain't gonna lie bro I scream
like I'm sitting on the couch bro like
yeah I like I yell like
oh yeah
I'm going over my phone and seeing this
play right here I did the same yells and
all that but I wish I would have saw
live though for sure
that's crazy right there that's what you
want right now in the game bro bro
that's our Dream scenario if it ain't a
sack Force fumble fumble recovery
touchdown that's what came on Thibodeau
had one of those in the Giants game but
we get back to that what but um you know
that's our Dream scenario for a
defensive lineman man and you know it's
dope that Chandler had got his dope that
you know he's having some success he
started seizing off a little bit slow
had a great game last week week before
that he had a second a week before that
he had three sacks so it just shows you
like Chandler ain't never out like he
just waiting to strike and if you really
watch Chandler game like he winning and
he whooping ass like bro every single
every step
the sex is not coming but if you're
really watching and you put eyes on it
like bro Chandler's still the same
Chandler man so shout out to Chandler
Jones it's our dog man and you know
that'd be a dream for us to you know
have that play and then you have your
whole sideline come you know jump crazy
come jump on it yeah fans throwing stuff
at you in a good way
to the Raiders that was their second
game like that that was it no they lost
to the they lost to the Arizona
Cardinals the Cardinals are saying well
not the same way but fumble recovery
touchdown in overtime hey man so shout
out to the Raiders man Max Crosby and
challenge those are my guys man the
Titans had a wild interception too
that play was crazy too it's been a
crazy defensive week man you know the
guy throw it back in he get the ball
just just to have the just to have the
mental awareness to like catch it I'm
going out of bounds throw it back into
my guy
this yeah that's definitely interception
of the year like look at that bro 100
interception of the year like I said
brother mental focus alone was just
throwing it back in even if brother
didn't catch it that's still impressive
you know what I mean
like bro I'm gonna throw it back in he
with somebody grabbed me you're pulling
trying to pull you down yeah that's hard
man it's crazy man
um you know speaking of all these
defensive plays it's been some crazy
um calls that should have been passing
their fans that wasn't passing offense I
mean it was it was a crazy end of the
game
um situation versus the Giants and the
commanders you know that that probably
costing the game
um it's been a lot of talk about
you know rest missing calls should we
bring back
um shall we bring back the uh the review
where we can review defensive pass in
defense and all that stuff and I'm just
saying like no bro like that's just part
of the game like yeah that's part of the
game like sometimes the refs get it
right some and they try their best to
get it right they do like they watch
film and they do all the stuff that we
do but you know sometimes you just you
just miss a call like and that's what
make our that's what the the the
variable of the ref like making a great
call or making a bad call that's what
people want to see like you know what
I'm saying like rest job is hard too the
restaurant is hard too if you just take
if you just take the power off the rep
of the ref hands and you just have
everything reviewable then what type of
game is that like with no reps out there
like we need the rest that's what that's
what football is out you got offense
defense special teams and the refs you
know that's that's all you need all
those things to play good football what
do you think about yourself you think
you should have a you think you should
have reviewable
um situations in a game like that
I feel like it's a celebrity slow bro
like sometimes uh it might go one way
you know what I mean and then you know
I'm saying I feel like every passing
defense You're Gonna Want to be reviewed
and stuff like that and then it's going
to slow the game down let's go do a
whole bunch of stuff but like you said
man nobody's perfect bro rest gonna call
a play here call play there they might
mess up a couple times but we need rest
for the Integrity of the game man they
do a lot of good things man and uh like
you say you just can't take the power
out the rest hands and put it all on
video then what's the that's that takes
a variable out of our game so it's not
the same football no more what you think
about
what you think about um reference calls
uh
they're annoying bro but I feel like
they could just be a little bit more
defined I feel like and not have that
definition be a slippery slope either
because I remember I've been a part of
we both we both of them had some we both
of them had some crazy ass some crazy
hours rough in the past were like what I
barely went and that cost us the game in
Denver right and a lot like you said a
lot of them cost you a game a lot of
them put you in bad scenarios so I just
feel like it's like it has to be
definitive bro like okay yeah I slammed
them here but if I I saw Jalen Phillips
this year he's been he had a crazy spin
on uh on the right tackle from this from
the Chargers tackled him and I landed on
his on his all fours and they still
caught roughing so I mean it's a
slippery slope like one of those two man
if you start reviewing it and stuff
looks worse on review when you slow it
down stuff looks a lot worse okay your
hand might have scraped his face mask we
could call face mask there so yeah I
mean it's just one of those things man
it's just annoying you just gotta wish
that you on the right side of it yeah
just let the rest call it man you add
you with Tyreek Hill Jalen waddle Raheem
mostert like bro it's insane tour
um Tyreek Hill you know he leads Madden
in all speed ratings
um you know first I started still I
start like a little story about Tyreek
Hill of course we're going to the Pro
Bowl each and every year like back when
Tyree first got there so you you're able
to spend a lot of time with us and um it
was just one time like we was at
practice and I was like
man you stink I'm still I'm gonna start
calling you little stink bro like I
started calling you a snake of course he
didn't stinking anything like that I was
just you know what I'm saying just
joking you know sometimes I might go up
to a guy meet him for the first time and
I'd be like bro you ugly bro yeah I'm
glad you calling football bro
I'm glad you call this a football and
then just throw guys off you know my
first time ever meeting guys
first time ever me guys like this year
Jalen waddle was in the game my first
time ever meeting him got helmet on like
welcome to him I said damn well you you
ugly as hell but you can play some
football now are you cold but you ugly
man hey you can play some football man
you cold
like you
you got these stories like that about
Tyreek Hill or Jalen wattle I know they
took they two cool guys man you got yeah
they've been there that long ago man you
got any stories before I remember my
first interaction with Tyreke man I uh I
was at the the Chicago game I went up to
him I was like hey bro I'm gonna lie to
you but I used to hate you man you know
being on the Chiefs being me being on
the Broncos I said hey I used to hate
you man I'm I'm so glad we on the same
team now I'm so glad I'm on your team
and I remember he just said hey man I'm
on your team man so boom right there
right there in there squash the beef you
know I mean the internal beef I had we
squashed it and then Waterman he could
like I said the both of them boys cool
as a fan man they just they they know
they got it man you know what I mean
like they walk around like they know
they got it but not walking around in
the sense of having their nose up at
people man they just walk with that swag
with that confidence everywhere and uh
they great teammate saying what's up to
everybody have the locker room laughing
all the time so those two they Dynamic
man I'm so glad they're having the
season they have what about Ibrahim
Mozart like I I you know GM had on again
like yeah I got coach McDaniels in his
run his run scheme and then most there
too like you know he was doing the same
thing he was doing with the 49ers like
he's fast he's extremely fast he's he's
powerful as well you got any stories
about uh Mozart no I know stories but
that's that's a good dude too man he's
locking right across uh the way from
mine so I talked to him how long every
chance I get uh like you said man just
blazing fast in that field dog it's
crazy the things he could do with the
ball in his head man and uh I'm
I'm excited to see how he continues to
turn it up bro he had a crazy game this
past week had a hundred and like the
first half of some crazy like that first
half like it was crazy I was like
somebody please subscribe tackle this
guy can you at least scratch him jeez he
was running like he wasn't trying to go
down and that was the worst yeah that
was the worst running backs to go
against like the running backs that that
ain't scared like imma break this talk
and I'ma still wiggle for some more man
so a lot of respect for Mozart too
um tour is a crazy athlete too what
about you know his work ethic and you
know what makes two of special yeah man
like I said what I talked about two
earlier he's the same dude every day man
do the same routine do all this uh stuff
he need to do to get right man and I
just feel like the the mindset he has
makes him special bro cause he got all
the guy giving the ability Talent you
know what I mean and
um the just how he approaches it how his
mindset is how he talks to people how he
gets the guys around him to play for him
because as a quarterback bro I feel like
you could be as cold as you want to be
but if guys around you not playing for
you then yeah then what do you really
have you know what I mean so he does a
good job of that man and I'm excited to
see what he how he's gonna finish this
season off because we're gonna need him
big in these next three weeks making
that playoff push they're gonna need a
lot of guys so excited to see how
everybody responds that quarterback
position is so crazy man it's probably
the toughest position
in all of sports like of course you know
I feel like the most physically the the
the the most
um demanding physically will have to be
cornerback and all of sports because I'm
guarding the guy and he's fast he's
quick he's on the page with the
quarterback and I can't touch him I
can't do nothing so when you see guys
like Patrick like Patrick certain and
you see guys like JC horn and you see
guys like I got Trey white and Zay
Howard you see these guys cover these
wide receivers one-on-one without
touching them like that is the most
demanding uh sport that is the most
demanding position in all of sports I'm
talking about basketball soccer all
sports and then the most demanding
mentally
is the quarterback position and tour is
definitely one of the best quarterbacks
in the AFS in the AFC division but there
are also some other great quarterbacks
in the AFC division as well you know as
pass rushers we have a unique point of
view about quarterbacks you know we we
talked about Derek Carr for a long time
like we all have respect and love for
Derek Carr even though they weren't
winning we was like okay like he wanted
them ones um yeah you know who are your
who are your top quarterbacks in the
conference from from Bradley Chubb well
you got it don't have to be you know
this guy's the best it could just you
know what's what's some of the guys that
you admire yeah no order at all for sure
but my homes of course you know I mean
all the things he did even though I
can't stand those those teeth being in
Denver and stuff like that got to give
credit where credit do so for show my
homes uh Herbert I feel like uh I used
to tell him all the time man you're one
of my favorite young quarterbacks bro
like every time we played him no matter
if I hit him or not I'll tell him maybe
you you got it bro just keep going so uh
he's one of my favorites for sure uh who
else who else two of course Joe burrow I
love I love to see the things he do he
does in Cincinnati I feel like Trevor
Lawrence coming on real strong these
past couple games man it's good to see
him like living up and like doing what
he do
um
man this is the first thing I told Josh
I like man I'm glad you're on my team
but every time I don't play you I don't
gotta say exactly you're gonna give me
one of them sacks you know what I'm
saying it then I say Dion bro every time
I play you you're gonna you know you're
gonna let me you know spin inside and
get me inside you can do so you're gonna
give it to me I said I'm glad we're on
the same team but y'all gonna give it to
me every single time man you're gonna
get yours regardless now of course
yeah Josh Ellen for sure of course Josh
Allen man and I I'm blanking on names
right now but it's so many quarterbacks
out there bro that you could name and
put them in yeah I am top five whatever
you want to put them in it I feel like
that listed interchangeable every week
man just no matter it's crazy Any Given
Sunday is crazy
these guys are souped up these days you
know um as of right now as of today your
first round playoff matchup would be
versus the Chiefs how do you feel about
that matchup man you know I'm ready to
go bro uh anytime I got a chance to play
them Brad hey I'm gonna give my all dog
a show so uh the way things go right now
if that's the matchup it's gonna be dope
man it's gonna be a uh kind of like a
like a uh
a circle moment bro like everything
coming together like you're saying being
in Denver and not being able to get past
that hump and being on a new team a new
situation and being faced with that same
obstacle again so it's gonna be dope
hopefully it works out like that right
but we're gonna play these last three
out man and make sure we make the most
of them but if that were to happen I
know Tyreke will be happy I know I would
be happy so it'll be it'll be dope
man that's how it was for me man you
know we I think the Broncos they haven't
beaten the Chiefs in seven years since
2000 crazy 15. and whenever we went to
um whenever we went to
um Kansas City to play the Chiefs like
it was just one of those games for me
like I you know I like going in I like
going to Kansas City and playing the
Chiefs because
Derek Thomas is one of my favorite
players I wore 58 because of Derrick
Thomas
um I always feel like I got like a
little Dairy timer Spirit on me when I
play there I haven't played there in a
while I didn't play there in 2020 and I
didn't play there in 2021 I got traded
before he played the Chiefs in 2020 I
didn't play at all so going back there
and playing the Chiefs and playing
Patrick Mahomes and all of those guys it
just felt like okay this is why they
brought me in here you know I can I
gotta I got a new team this team is is
better equipped to play the Chiefs
um you know I'm ready to play we got
Josh Allen all these guys man I'm ready
to play the Chiefs and I think that show
that showed for me because every single
play like I was on like I never really
thought like whenever I was playing the
Chiefs I never I always felt like I
could have played more I feel like I
could have gotten more for myself but at
the same time I felt like damn like if I
was on like this team or that team then
we can beat them boys so it was kind of
like it was kind of like you know a
little bit of a validation for me to go
there with the Chiefs and my new team
and and and play those guys and get a
win a hard fart win like it wasn't one
of those fluke wins where the guy from
the ball and you know we get up it was
like a real hard fart it was a proper
scrap and we won that mug so in the way
that you had a lot
yeah yeah you know when you when you can
contribute too that's why that's why
they brought you know that's why they
brought me here the whole 13 seconds and
all of that and go out there and and do
your job man chub you know how that you
know how they feel to like go out there
and do your job man so when y'all go
there and play the Chiefs man I'm hoping
y'all boys go out there and and win I'm
hoping y'all go out there and be the
Chiefs because we know how dangerous the
Chiefs can be in the playoffs so it
wouldn't be anything better Bradley tub
go crazy on the Chiefs I I would love
that man for show for sure man
um Before I Let You Go
you know I want to play a game with you
man about you and your teammates
um you know you know I'm a team guy yeah
I'm a team guy you know I love being
around my teammates man I love like the
whole like Dynamic of being in a locker
room and getting annoying God where they
came from what high schools they went to
what type of cars they like how many
kids they got are they married or they
not like what making them go I really
enjoy that part of football just as much
as playing football man I've always been
a locker room guy and I know that you're
just now getting to to know your
teammates but I want to play a game
uh it's called most likely too and I'm
gonna read off to you some some things
and you just tell me which one of your
teammates are most likely is is this
most likely to be you got me yeah I got
you
all right I'm gonna start with this one
who is most likely to show up late to
practice
so I'd like to practice uh uh Melvin
Melvin Ingram I would say my dog I was
gonna say Fargo man I'm Gonna Save Me
Over I ain't gonna lie to you you know
that's my dog
but I love Melvin bro that's like that's
like my dog bro like yeah and the whole
league I've been knowing Melvin like
since way way like way back way back
when like yeah we just both signed the
Gatorade together I came out a year
before him so I was kind of like the
older guy like bringing the younger
Gatorade God man ever since then we
signed to the same agent and you know
that's the reason why I started wearing
my ice in my Jerry like yeah yeah Melvin
and the keep to leave like those
ice on it you know man he's gonna tell
you about the new whip this is the new
this is the rafe like yeah you know
you're gonna you're gonna feel crummy if
you ain't you know what I'm saying
but yeah that's how you got Memphis I
get in the mail I ain't gonna lie to you
most likely to spend five hours on tick
tock most likely to spend five hours of
tech talk Brandon Jones
Brandon Jones social media guy man that
boy he stay on Tick Tock every day I get
on there he got two new video three new
videos up so I know he'd be looking at
the trends and all that so for sure
most likely to sit front front row at
Fashion Week
uh Xavier Howard for sure
he come with it on there today ain't
gonna lie to you come with it on there
day no matter what I'm saying walk
through travel trip you come with it on
so I get to him for sure but that's how
Steph that's how Stefan Stefan Diggs is
bro like yeah it's insane like I know
y'all see the swag and stuff like on
Blitz Blitz splits and you know you know
all those pages but until you see it
like up close and personal like you know
he he really be putting it on fam yeah
bro
if you're doing this like what's up bro
you just got that mind to do it like
this like it's crazy you know come up
with those fits week after week is God
you got to go home and kind of come up
with some type of Playbook some type of
some type of plan well they just do it
bro he's swaggy on and off the football
field and it's dope to hear that Zay is
the same way
um most likely
to be king of the aux cord on a road
trip
uh
uh man it might be me yeah cause I feel
like I ain't we ain't had nobody really
take charge of the auction locker room
or the weight room and it's just kind of
like playing it's playing hits but it
ain't nobody like really taking charge
of it so I I get that to myself for sure
first thing I did when I got in the
locker room I got these two big speakers
boom these two bow speakers
I already know about my DJ stuff that's
the first thing I did bro like you
remember back in Denver they come in
they turned down the music yeah here in
Buffalo they like turn that up turn it
up the whole the whole locker room the
whole locker room going crazy bro and
everybody love it bro so I would be the
king of the auction in my locker room um
most likely to eat the cleanest
uh
probably Jaylen Phillips dude look like
an action figure you know what I'm
saying six five two six like an action
figure so you know I mean I'll probably
give to him
he chiseled man um most like most likely
to squat the most
uh
most likely to squat the most probably
for Christian Wilkins
I was just about to say that man yeah
beast on the inside yeah bro he got he
huge too bro he not like no you know I'm
saying just like a big dude he like fit
he got the good like being good all that
good everything you need from a
defensive lineman he got it for sure I I
know a deep text I know we had Draymond
Jones when he was in Denver everybody
wanted to run that text with Draymond
sir he's like I'm trying to be with Dre
man I try to get a Drake like Chris
Christian that's your God that's your
God yeah no doubt no doubt and then we
got another dude Zach Silo on the inside
he'll be doing some good stuff too man
so
um all those guys man all the guys in
the d-line room outside Lineback room
trying to get at it man for sure pushing
each other every day
for sure man
um most likely to eat the most at a team
dinner
uh
uh John Jenkins
John Jenkins yeah when you're putting
them calories equal everyone got to get
them calories I'm just saying that
because my dog did yeah you know what
I'm
saying
about that tomorrow so yeah he might not
even eat that much he might not even eat
that much but I know he a big dude so
I'm gonna just give it to him yeah man
we I mean we still learning our
teammates man um who's who's most likely
to pick up the tab
uh now it's me bro now it's me man we
gotta go and put them chips out there
man I'll try to slide the card in
without everybody seeing and stuff like
that I want to see what I'm saying love
on the quiet tip for sure yeah that's my
God man
um most likely to start in the movie
most likely to start in the movie uh
I get that to either
two or Tyree they're the Stars man they
do everything they need to be done on
the field and I know they could the
acting skills probably A1 so I'll give
it one of them boys for sure
most likely to hit a half court shot
most likely to hit a half court shot uh
who's the Hooper who's the Hooper on the
team okay I've never I ain't seen the
hoopers yet but if I had to go off just
like
just body even saying appearance and
body style I have to say
I'll say my dog uh van ginkel man van
gink man he he oh yeah yeah I don't know
if he could shoot or not but he'd be
making plays on the field bro he making
plays that you wouldn't think he would
make on the field so I could see him
doing the same thing on the court
yeah I'm a fan I think you know the guys
that we played would probably be Bradley
Chubb right not me not Bradley probably
be courting Sutton right corner yeah 100
yeah yeah
I mean Justin Simmons Justin
yeah that's it that's that's
pay-per-view right there 101 of course
but them boys really like hoopers though
so it's different that's a different
level
um most likely to uh finish a thousand
piece puzzle
yeah I say Connor Williams
I don't even know if he could but he's
locking right next to mine so I'm gonna
say him
um uh most likely to have the best
cologne
uh
uh probably my dog Fargo again mail
again him saying he's going to stay with
with all the all the latest you know
what I mean so he probably gonna smell
the best too yeah for sure man
um you know chub man that that's it for
us man you know I I love you man real
love man that love you stuff I love
YouTube it was a it's an honor and
privilege to play with you man I've I've
witnessed your passion firsthand and I'm
just so happy and excited for you to be
able to to channel that energy into a
team that's on the way up right now the
Denver Broncos they they on their way
too but the Miami Dolphins they ready
right now and they needed a player like
you man and me stepping back and looking
at the situation man I'm so happy for
you man I'm so happy for your family man
like you of Miami guy like we love
Denver but South Beach chub come on man
come on it sounds great to me Southeast
shut up man I'm so excited for you man
with the contract man hopefully we'll
see some little ones so so Val and
victory can have you know a little
little brothers the beat up on them how
you sound like can go kick it with uh
kick it with a little tub all right man
yeah for sure
if you if you ever need anything from me
if it's just like a FaceTime call if
it's you know a video if if it's
anything that you need from me man you
know I got you man my my college coach
coach Sherman he said a good friendship
is a friendship where you give and take
give and take and I don't want to be
like that man I I want to give and I
want to take and whatever you need from
me man just just let me know man send me
a text man send me a FaceTime you know
I'm gonna be there man I love you bro I
appreciate you for coming on the show
man thank you man for real I already
know it bro I love you too man I
appreciate you having me man like I said
all the things you don't taught me
without even knowing all the things you
taught me with knowing I appreciate you
man help me out a lot for sure
I appreciate you telling me you never
know man you know six years I get done
playing six years
five you're five there man you never
know man you never know man you never
know
I love terrible I appreciate you man I
love brother we got some fan questions
right here it says mike 89 if you could
take any player from another team and
put him on the bills who would you take
um
uh
if I could take any player from another
team
I would take uh
uh probably
Zay Zay Howard from the Miami Dolphins
and I will put them on our team that way
you know we don't you know that way you
know our receivers can run free and that
way you know Josh Allen he won't be
giving Josh Allen problems and we'll
just go crazy then because you know that
defense uh that the Miami Dolphins got
man it is a strong defense and if you
take Zay out and you put him on our team
like you know I think that that
definitely gives us the edge but you
know he's still on the Miami Dolphins
he's a great player you know I love the
guy on and off the football field man
and that would be you know my gut that I
would take
um it says Trey young Stan I saw today
that you were done recruiting obj is
that true
you know what sometimes in the media
they just they just say things right
they just
they just say things that uh
you know that that get blown out of
proportion I ain't never done recruiting
obj
you know the ball is in obj's court
though you know if obj wants you know
the play he gonna play you know I'm not
speaking for obj but I'm just saying
like obj is going to do what's best for
obj and um you know that's my guy and
just because I take I say I'm taking a
step back from the recruiter and taking
a step forward as a brother doesn't mean
that I don't want him on the Buffalo
Bills doesn't mean that he's not coming
to the Buffalo Bills what it means is
that
Odell Beckham is doing what's best you
know for Odell Beckham which I am all
for you know he has a young son you know
he got a young family
um he's going to do what's best for him
you know he took the Team friendly deal
last year and came to the Los Angeles
Rams and you know he he already did all
that man and I want obj to be happy
because I've been around a happy obj man
and a happy obj a playmaking obj like
that's what the league needs man and you
know I'm excited for obj in his next
chapter whether he comes back and plays
in the regular season this year or he
comes back and he plays in the playoffs
or he signs a crazy contract and free
agency like you guys have not seen the
end of obj man and I'm excited to see
what obj does next whether that's with
the Buffalo Bills or whoever man shout
out to obj man I love you bro
um
we got the Bears this week
and this is this is a sneaky team you
know I don't think that I don't think
that this team is a uh the record is a
clear indicator of what type of team
that they are got a lot of respect for
Justin fields and the things that he's
done he's only the third quarterback in
NFL history to rush for a thousand yards
I think that you know he's he's he's
reading and if it's not there he's gone
and that's what you should do um that's
what he should do man he's not going to
spend a lot of time back there and just
let guys tee off on him and Sack him you
know he's he's doing they're playing to
his skill set and he's a great Runner um
he's still learning how to pass the ball
better but he's a he's a great Runner he
has all the tools to be you know one of
the best quarterbacks ever in NFL
history and I think that um you know
he's doing what works right now and that
those those type of players and those
type of teams are dangerous and um you
know this this bearish team is dangerous
they got a solid defense
um Justin Fields could change a game in
any in any moment they play hard they
they play tough for their new head coach
and it's the it's the it's the Chicago
Bears man like it's the Chicago Bears
and they they always have a tough gritty
team and this week it's going to be
snowy cold windy
um it's gonna be a really really cold
game in Chicago on Christmas Eve so it's
gonna be a tough game it's because the
elements are definitely gonna be a
factor in this game and
you know we just had to go out there and
do what the Buffalo Bills do best
um I got a another fan question
um it says Audi mark
real Christmas tree or fake Christmas
tree
white lights or multicolored lights
um I'm definitely I'm looking at my
Christmas tree right now I'm definitely
a fake Christmas tree guy and I'm
definitely a like white light type
classical like Christmas tree guy
um you know I I want a Christmas tree to
like
I honestly I've never had a real
Christmas tree in my house like I'm from
Texas you know Desoto Texas like that's
just not what we did we we didn't go get
real Christmas trees and and put them up
so it's just that's just not something
I'm used to I'm used to really really
beautiful fake trees with um we're
really really we're really beautiful
lights on it and um we don't even put we
don't even put like gifts under our
trees anymore we just get like boxes and
we wrap them up we could probably get
like a Louis V box or a Gucci box and we
just you know wrap them up and it's just
all for decoration we put like a train
around it and it's off for decoration so
I'm all I'm all about getting a fake
treat that looks really really nice
um
you know I always like to uh you know
have a a theme song for a track song for
the weeks that we play and this week
we're playing the Chicago Bears
and um
this week's title will have to be
going with the wind in Chicago and this
song is one of those feel-good songs
it's not one of those hard like future
like Drake like just stepping on
everybody type songs 21 Savage it's not
one of those songs this is like one of
those this is like
future and uh
this is like a this is like future and
like Rihanna like you know like the love
song like that love like this is a love
song where you thankful you know for
your teammates you thankful for the fans
so right before Christmas we're playing
on Christmas Eve it's all about love and
um
and great energy and you know um singing
that song for a special loved one that's
what this is man you know um going with
the wind and the windy city in the windy
going with the wind in the windy city
that would be my song title and um that
is it for this week's Von cast it is an
honor and a privilege to come here with
you guys each and every week
shout out to everybody involved shout
out to uh to Bleacher Report um shout
out to all the guys behind the scenes
the infrastructure of the voncast that
really makes this thing go
um they really supported me and put me
in great situations to put forward a
great product each and every week
so I want to say thank you guys all the
guys behind the scenes from The Tech
Guys to the producers to everybody
that's doing all the hard work to make
it go man it's an honor to privilege to
do this each and every week and I
appreciate you guys and that's this
week's Von cast
thank you
[Music]